growing up in detroit and boston in the
50s and 60s dr ben carson
experienced prejudice and racism
personally
it's why even he speaks about the new
institutional racism
against black conservatives when he does
so everyone should listen
it's not anything that's any different
than
many many years ago during slavery
if you ran away you got caught they
didn't just kill you
they brought you back and they tormented
you
in front of everybody else so that they
would get the lesson
do not run away
wow dr ben carson former hud secretary
founder of the american cornerstone
institute joins me now
wow dr carson that was i mean it was
chilling
um but you told the truth uh
and it gets you slandered explain why
you needed to
say it that way it is a chilling thing
that people actually think it's okay
on the left side to characterize someone
on the basis
of their skin color of external
characteristics
you know as a neurosurgeon obviously i
spent a lot of time working on people's
brains
and you know once i got inside of that
skull
i couldn't tell whether you were black
or white or yellow
or red the brain is the same
and the brain is the thing that makes
you who you are and why should we be
so superficial you know animals
have a tendency to look at external
characteristics and react to those
because they don't have the intellectual
ability
to analyze deeper than that but we do
have that ability
and we really need to stop it and you
know i think one of the reasons that
so many people were afraid of
the previous president is because he
was actually you know not just saying
words but he was actually doing things
that
really made a difference in the minority
communities
and you know they're not stupid yeah
they were seeing what was happening
yeah they're seeing results democrats
have rhetoric and demonization
but they have nothing to show for it uh
and by the way i don't know if you saw
this but
your old pal reverend al sharpton
had some choice words to say about you
dr carson watch
marcia fudge was sworn in as secretary
of housing and urban development this
week
she will now have to lead an agency
where the morale among civil servants
has plummeted under the leadership of
ben carson
who weakened fair housing enforcement
and other civil rights protections
during the trump administration dr
carson
uh his criticism of your policies
goes right to race your response
well it does go right to race it's
almost as if he's
reading off of a script and they all say
the same kinds of things
they don't actually look at what was
done at the progress that was made in
moving people towards self-sufficiency
that's what we really should be thinking
about and our definition of success was
how many people we got out of those
programs of dependency
and move them in the right direction and
you know
we just need to sort of get beyond this
third grade
let's criticize whoever it was and
let's build upon what each other does
you know
the american people are not each other's
enemies
and we have to stop allowing ourselves
to be manipulated into thinking that
you know that's one of the reasons for
the american cornerstone
institute so that we can actually deal
with the
facts not with the rhetoric not with the
ideology
let's put the facts on the table and
then let's determine what the problems
are and let's work together to solve
them
if we do that it can still be e pluribus
unum
out of many one instead of
even unemployment tearing everything
apart
oh fantastic dr carson wonderful to see
you thank you so much